bonjour à toutes et à tous waouh trop de
changements il a changé de coupe de
cheveux il a changé le micro rien ne va
plus écoutez il faut bien que j'évolue
com - honda donc on passe au set-up de
2021 et puis les cheveux ça repoussera
bien je vais pas vous mentir que le
sujet de wayne la vision est assez
complexe et si je n'en parle que
maintenant ce n'est pas un hasard
les trois premiers épisodes servait à la
mise en place de la série nous faire
comprendre toute la problématique de la
sitcom et même si on se doute que ce
n'est pas réel et bas tout est flou ok
il y a des références glamor et inuh
jeunes c'est une référence au couple
d'amis du rwanda et vision qui sont
magicien dans les comics et c'est leur
nom de scène ou bien tout simplement les
pubs etc etc
c'est cool mais ça n'apporte pas
énormément au récit j'attendais donc
l'épisode 4 un épisode qui est cool mais
qui au final résume plus ou moins
simplement les trois premiers épisodes
donc je n'avais pas vraiment grand chose
à dire c'est donc avec cet épisode 5 que
je décide enfin de prendre la parole de
vous raconter mes idées mes théories ma
vision des choses
vision accompli bref comme je vous
disais rwanda et vision est quand même
assez difficile à traiter car même si
tout semble à peu près logique pour un
fan lambda de marvel et bat tous restent
extrêmement floues pourquoi une sitcom
quel est le but de la série comme en
ouganda eu de tels pouvoirs
quel est l'impact du sword quel est le
véritable rôle de monica rambo dans tout
ça et c'est là je pense ou le dernier
épisode de one la vision sera très
important car pour bien traiter de one
la vision il faut garder en tête
certaines choses ou nda vision est une
série du mc eu ce qui veut dire que oui
on se base sur les comics mais de
manière très ouverte
beaucoup d'éléments vont être repris
mais réadapté pour l'histoire que veut
instaurer disney et marvel studios
c'est toujours bon de le rappeler
également au rwanda vision est la
première partie d'une longue histoire
début de la phase 4 et le prêt qu'elle a
doctor strange 2 multivers of madness
ainsi que spider man 3 c'est hyper
important de garder ça en tête
tout simplement car rwanda vision est
comme une introduction nous n'aurons
peut-être pas toutes les réponses aux
mystères dans la série mais dans la
suite des événements
et justement il est fort possible que
wendat vision amène des éléments qui
auront un impact pour l'avenir du mcf
pour revenir plus concrètement à
l'épisode 5 et mes théories
je vous invite d'ailleurs à partager les
vôtres en commentaire un joli évidemment
tous vos avis et vos idées à chaque fois
c'est un vrai plaisir et je profite
également ce moment pour vous informer
que vous êtes beaucoup à regarder les
vidéos sans être abonné à la chaîne
n'hésitez pas à le faire profiter en
lacets le moment car c'est le début on
va dire d'une grande série de vidéos où
on va parler de warda vision de la phase
4 de l'avenir du mc eu etc
je suis obligé de vous parler de
méphisto car je suis un grand partisan
de sa présence on parle quand même d'un
mec qui a fait de nicholas cage le ghost
rider
on va aux tirs amis
poste endgame rwanda a tout perdu pietro
est mort face à hull tron vision a été
tué par thanos hawkeye même si les
proches d'elle baïla sa famille sa vie à
faire et le collectif des avengers est
en quelque sorte dix sous tony est mort
captain a pris sa retraite banner est en
quelque sorte partie de son côté on va
dire bref rwanda et dans une grande
solitude et a perdu tous ses proches
c'est là que méphisto intervient wendat
nous apprend dans l'épisode 5 que ce
n'est pas elle qui a démarré tout ce qui
se passe à west view néanmoins elle en a
le contrôle
elle peut risette quand quelque chose ne
l'arrangent pas et décide et qui rentre
ou sort de la ville comme avec monica
par exemple c'est un véritable cadeau
empoisonné
nous savons que dans les comics wendat
souhaite mener une vie simple et
heureuse et que c'est justement à cause
de ces dangereux pouvoir que house of m
naîtra une réalité parallèle créé par
rwanda qui lui permettra de façonner
notre vie à tout le monde et par rapport
à son histoire personnelle
tommy et billy sont une partie
emblématique de sa vie elle qui ne peut
pas avoir d'enfant normalement car
vision est un synthé zoïde ce cadeau
empoisonné
key west view est arrivé à oujda pile au
moment où elle était au fond seuls et
désemparés
sauf que c'est là qu'un lien peut se
faire avec doctor strange qui va
d'ailleurs renforcé ce qui se passera
dans doctor strange 2 comme il l'a
expliqué lui-même et notamment avec la
scène où il se fait engueuler par mort
dos tout à un prix comme avec la gemme
de l'espace ondes peut aller contre les
lois qui régissent l'univers donc
manipuler le temps manipuler la vie etc
et ça même au rwanda en a conscience au
vu de sa réaction face à la mort de ce
parti elle en est même inquiète
tommy et billy vont à l'encontre des
lois qui régissent l'univers
et ça ou honda en paiera le prix pour
les plus dans le détail concernant
méphisto et pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas forcément le
personnage c'est un démon et plus
exactement un démon extra dimensionnelle
la particularité de ce dernier et qu'il
n'est pas un méchant à proprement parler
il est un équivalent de ce qu'on peut
imaginer du diable mais il n'est pas le
diable évidemment méphisto possède sa
propre réalité où il cherche à acquérir
des âmes et comme pour le cas du film
ghost rider il va proposer de réaliser
un désir fou ou un rêve à la personne
convoitée en échange de son âme
et tout comme l'eau qui concernant la
tromperie c'est un personnage
extrêmement vicieux qui peut se jouer
des personnes est manipulée pour arriver
à ses fins c'est là où cela prend sens
west view offre à rwanda la vie qu'elle
a toujours rêvé d'avoir
et comme le fruit défendu dujardin
d'adam et eve est bien un rwanda a cédé
à la tentation et là où le vi va encore
plus loin c'est par rapport à vision
j'aurais eu tendance à penser à la base
que méphisto aurait pris l'apparence de
wendat pour voler le corps de vision et
le faire renaître dans west view afin
d'appâter encore plus longue
sauf qu'au vu de sa haine et sa
détermination il serait possible que
wendat en réalisant le pouvoir qu'elle
possède dans west view le fait de créer
la vie manipuler la réalité et adapter
les éléments dedans comme pour le coût
des vêtements de monica par exemple elle
aurait eu l'idée d'aller chercher le
corps de vision pour lui redonner vie et
pouvoir enfin mener une vie paisible à
ses côtés mais à la manière de
frankenstein la créature se retourne
contre son créateur et en réanimant
vision ce dernier conserve ses pouvoirs
de synthèse aux ide est donc là j'aime
de l'esprit puisque wendat l'aurait
remodelé en fonction de ses derniers
souvenirs
ce qui fait qu'il se rend compte petit à
petit de la supercherie et au vu du
twist final la venue de méphisto
commence sérieusement à se faire
ressentir de mon côté
au milieu de la dispute de couple pietro
est envoyée pile poil au bon moment pour
interrompre la discussion afin de faire
maintenir le mystère west view encore
plus longtemps
sauf que ce n'est pas au rwanda qui l'a
envoyé alors qu' un être qui connaît ou
honda et qui cherche à la maintenir dans
ce rêve par rapport au fait que ce soit
le quiksilver des x men chapeau c'était
une belle surprise
mais je pense que ça reste un troll de
disney et de marvel studios
je pense qu'ils ont profité que west
view soit une réalité à part on va dire
un truc rempli de fake pour faire un
petit caméo du quicksilver des x men
la venue des x men sera bien plus tard
je pense personnellement évidemment je
n'oublie pas de mentionner à gneiss ou
agnès tout dépend de quel look vous
regardez qui devient de plus en plus
évident qu'elle est une adaptation
d'agatha harkness une autre sorcière qui
est du rwanda et la considère presque
comme sa fille dans les comics néanmoins
vu que nous sommes dans le mc eu je
garde en tête qu'agatha harkness ne soit
pas forcément adapté à l'écran et qu'au
final haguenets ce soit mephisto elle
même ce que je veux dire c'est que elle
est toujours là quand rwanda a besoin
d'elle
pile poil au bon moment c'est la seule
qui semble écouter wendat travers
lumière et sait pas trop comment bien
l'expliquer elle n'est pas une habitante
comme les autres et ce qui me perturbe
encore plus c'est la mort de ce parent
qui comme par hasard
agyness retrouve le chien mort avec une
bague excuses qu'il a bouffé plein de
feuilles de son rosiers ou je sais plus
quoi
c'est comme si elle testait wendat pour
voir ses pouvoirs
vu que les enfants ont dévoilé qu'elle
pouvait ressusciter le chien tout de
suite ça l'a interpellé à gonesse mais
ça reste une idée à part mais je la
garde quand même au coin de ma tête
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir
toute façon sur elle dans deux
prochaines vidéos dans tous les cas je
pense vraiment que méphisto est pour moi
un antagoniste parfaitement adapté à la
phase 4
et c'est ça qu'il faut déterminer il ne
faut pas un antagoniste pour seulement
wendat vision mais un antagoniste qui va
revenir dans les autres films notamment
docteur strange 2
nous venons de sortir d'un thanos au
sommet de sa puissance avec le gant de
l'infini
la phase 4 symbolise donc une sorte
d'après guerre
on ne peut pas directement enchaîné avec
un gros galactus énervé non on a besoin
de recentrer le récit introduire les
nouveaux personnages
les nouveaux héros et continuer
l'histoire des anciens avant de ramener
le grand spectacle
mephisto ne cherche pas à conquérir le
monde ou supprimer la moitié des
habitants de l'univers avec le gant mais
à manipuler les âmes et enrichir sa
dimension de ces dernières est là où il
est très pertinent pour la phase 4 sait
qu'il n'est pas au niveau de thanos avec
le gant mais il n'est pas non plus un
simple humain comme mystérieux il est un
démon une entité qui restent puissantes
et qui surtout possède sa propre
dimension
c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant de
le relier à strange qui est le seul
héros à pouvoir manipuler ces fameuses
dimension pour le moment et à en
comprendre tous le sens en tant que sur
ses suprêmes stephen strange a le devoir
de protéger le monde des créatures
dimensionnelle comme méphisto et les
êtres qui vont à l'encontre des lois qui
régissent l'univers
rappelez-vous de l'ancien qui ne
souhaitait pas fournir la perd du temps
à banner car cela allait dérégler le
cours de l'espace-temps créer des
réalités alternatives etc
enfin voilà la chute sera rude pour
rwanda le retour à la réalité va lui
faire très mal et je pense que ça va
être à doctor strange de gérer tout ça
sans oublier également le lien avec
spider man 3 mais on manque encore
d'éléments on va dire un petit peu là
dessus je vais arrêter là j'espère que
cette première vidéo sur word à vision
vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à me le
faire savoir dans les commentaires je
lis toujours tous vos avis et vos idées
c'est toujours un vrai plaisir
nous reparlerons bien évidemment de la
série dans les jours à venir et l'avenir
du mc eu de la phase 4 et cetera et puis
voilà quoi
je suis très heureux de vous avoir enfin
parler de la série
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus à
vous abonner évidemment c'est très
important que le lay ananas et très
pieux le lie à bleus à vous n'arrêtez la
méphisto
[Musique]